why do you love slash hey george
george kimmel your uh producer
what's your favorite thing about him
let's say that
positive thing positive
because you know it's like
you know i don't want to give them
compliments but you know i'll try yeah
yeah i'll try um
have you actually i i don't think you've
publicly ever said anything
i don't think i have either so i i'm
gonna get i'm gonna give it a go i'm
gonna give it a real girl here okay yeah
you know at the end of the day when it
comes to
money when it comes to responsibility
you know obviously this is a business
now
for you and me it is you know it's it's
a side business but it's a business
and um
you want to be able to trust the people
that are running it
and i have 100
trust in everything that he does in
terms of financial things in terms of
technical things in terms of
all of it you know i mean merchandise
and
i have 100
um belief in him i
and that's rare you know to find someone
like that um
also
at the end of the day i know his heart
and he really is
a great guy he there's nothing about him
like for instance
you know he was over the other day and i
go you know i bought this keith wooden
thing that some native man made
and i don't know how to put it on the
wall
so i just you know i go hey can you
figure this out and he goes yeah i got
it you know i mean like he's just that
guy yeah you know um
he's also but
but there is a part of me and this is
probably wrong yeah
but there's a part of me that feels like
i kind of made him
yeah he would be nothing with that no
that's not what i'm saying
i didn't [ __ ] say that's the way i
heard it i didn't that's what i meant
okay
but that's not what you said
it's probably wrong right because he did
all the things that he has in his life
he did on his own right right but still
for some reason he'd be nothing without
you
that's not what i'm saying but that's
what i mean yeah okay yeah so basically
like because when i
met him i was a part of this
um youtube studio called maker studios
and he was just a producer there and
that's how i met him and when he left
maker he came to us and he wasn't a
podcast producer and now he has this big
company he produces a bunch of podcasts
you know and he has a bunch of employees
and he has a nice business you know and
i feel like i had a lot to do with it so
both the competence and the good heart
yeah what about gilbert yeah gilbert is
a godsend as well you know i i don't
know if you because of let me ask you
this because you're a science guy
this is an interesting question for me
um
do you believe
just the universe gives you certain
things
at the right moment at the right time do
you believe that there is a mechanism
out there
where it's just we're just a part of
this machine that's kind of like
almost as if things are just happening
the way it's supposed to happen or do
you think this is these random
things that are hap occurring and we're
just it's chaos in that way i don't know
from a science perspective because i
wouldn't be able to explain it but i do
believe you mentioned karma there's
there's a karma thing
it just
if you put love out there in the world
like certain doors open in a certain
kind of way
like they're almost waiting for you and
then you walk through them so yes in
that way i believe
that it just it feels like um
not everything is like a basic like
billiard ball model of like
you have to fight for everything you
could just generally be cool to people
and kind to people and certain
opportunities just pop up
at the right moment more specifically
though you know so for instance
let's suppose like gilbert for instance
he just showed up at my house one day i
didn't know who it was i had a fight
night and a friend brought him right
this is right when
kaleila and i were starting tiger ballet
right and in conversation he was like we
didn't know how to
engineer
we didn't have an engineer for our
podcast and that night he was that you
know i know how to do it
right
and if i hadn't met him that night he
just wouldn't i don't know if it would
be as good it would be completely
different and i really believe that we
were abe
we met him that night for a reason you
know so you don't believe that
it's complicated i believe that for love
and these kinds of things but i don't
believe that as much for
building a team but that's the
engineering thing i think that's the
the artist in you
i'm less of an artist i think artists
thrive
in the chaos of it so it's not only that
you guys met at that time
is you didn't probably ask in detail
about his qualifications or didn't
didn't go through a rigorous thing you
just dove in
and figure it out on the fly i think
that's that's sort of the artist ethic i
think with like if you're doing a
startup or engineering there's a little
bit more rigor in in the selection
process
because the same was with rogan jamie
just walked up to him
uh
jamie vernon yeah yeah
yeah he just walked up to the same kind
of situation and they made it you know
uh both both of you have one of the best
podcasts in the world and so it's like
how did that
what
yeah i i i believe it's very strange
it's strange yeah maybe it's just like
cool people hang out with cool people so
you kind of collide that's not true
because they're because
that's not true because with bad friends
for instance right
um
i've had 12 people before andrew santino
that had asked me to do one with me
right
and you know they just was it wasn't
didn't want to do it yeah you know um
with andrew though it happened kind of
organically and in in in a way that was
almost like
in my heart
meant to happen
in a weird way that's a weird
combination by the way so why did why
was that the sticky one
because you have a lot of comedian
friends why andrew because number one
we both know
just instinctually without even talking
about it that in many ways we're polar
opposites in terms of like energy right
he's more aggressive i also know i
respond good with alpha males
you know i mean because i'm more of a
follower you know i mean or sensitive in
that way but in in many ways i am an
alpha male in certain areas of my life
you know yeah well you know when it
comes to smashing dot what's up you know
maybe yeah but you know so we both knew
instinctually that that in that way our
chemistry worked right and also in terms
of style and all that stuff is
completely just
it was just an organic given
to us
you